so all of these bands from back in the
day are you seeing whitening
we're like the outsider in a genre that
we created the tulips fan is a blast of
black girl magic all of us have
different styles but we bring it
together to give you this like fusion
almost different genres Diamond and
Crime Mob / management called me asked
me to do a video for her called mo
fester right now we were just an all
black girl band that was playing for
diamond simultaneously we developed the
tulips fan let's do something that may
have been attempted but we're gonna make
it our own who looks a spell like the
flower because we believe that cookie is
power tulips
[Music]
it kind of rubs people the wrong way and
they've expressed that to me like why
did you choose rock why is she trying to
be in this particular style if it was
never meant for her in the first place
being middle school high school being
that black girl that's in the rock I was
always calling like an Oreo I mean
growing up and going to an HBCU and
that's when I really understood wait a
minute we created this whole damn
general pioneers of rock like Sister
Rosetta Tharpe which is one of my great
inspirations of black woman that played
guitar and helped create this genre we
know as rock but a lot of people don't
know about her there have been many of
us before us that were just hiding
underneath everybody else now with
today's society we're just taking it
we're taking over we don't care
[Music]
we're constantly being taken advantage
of in the industry we had to represent
in this genre not just in the music and
she was specifically in this genre this
is something that we need and like we've
been doing this for so long you can see
the reaction on people's faces you're
like what then oh my god where'd y'all
come from that's why I think it's
important again for us to exist or
whatever we got to do the to look will
is it can't question that I'm real we're
real we're here and this is what we're
doing
[Music]
the fire
[Music]
instead of